hi everyone welcome to another episode
of q a about history of Science and
Technology I apologize for being
slightly late we were I was in another
live stream and I think we're getting
warmer and trying to find out
uh ways to see the discreetness of
space-time as it is supposed to be in
our models of fundamental physics
so that will be an exciting historical
thing when we managed to do that
um kind of the big analogy is the
discovery of molecules
um which had been long hypothesis even
from antiquity
and people had argued and particularly
from the 1600s on is matter discrete or
continuous that was really nailed down
only at the beginning of the 20th
century and with things like Brownian
motion being the the thing that uh
clinched it
um the uh uh the thing
that is interesting about Brownian
motion is as a phenomenon it had been
noticed 100 years earlier but its
interpretation in terms of molecules was
not noticed until the beginning of the
20th century and so it is our hope that
there are things like astrophysical
phenomena perhaps ones associated with
dark matter
um that have been known for a long time
like a century and not really explained
but which can when interpreted in terms
of discrete space time finally be
explained anyway we're I think we're
getting closer on that score but let me
turn now to questions people have here
so Zayden asks how did scientific
disciplines originate and evolve through
the centuries
interesting question
sort of where did where did the
different Sciences come from and what
was the kind of tree of uh evolution of
the Sciences one question is is it a
tree
is it the case that one started off with
sort of one Ur protoscience and that
sort of split up into many pieces and it
continues to split up or are there
mergers where two things that looked
like they were different Sciences end up
actually being the same story I think
there are examples of mergers where
people realize that things that they've
been studying in one direction for
example things they might have been
studying about biology are really just
the same as things that were being
studied about chemistry but I think
probably it is a more dramatic
phenomenon that that science has sort of
split apart
so what was the first uh science I
suppose it might have actually been in
the city of uh in uh ancient Babylonia
um perhaps or in in general in the in in
Babylonian times
um and I suppose that the question that
was probably originating one for science
is sort of can you predict what's going
to happen
and the question of predicting what's
going to happen was really something
that astrologers were the people
supposed to do that and the question of
how you do that is something where
people just had no idea what kind of a
thing
would lead to a prediction and what
kinds of things could be predicted and
so people were looking at doing
divination trying to Divine out the what
would happen by looking at different
kinds of things like they might look at
the The Notches on the bone of a sheep
or something or the entrails of a goat
or some such other thing and they might
say because the notches on the shoulder
blade of a sheep have this form
therefore it will rain tomorrow or
therefore this King will win such and
such a battle
or
early on
they will be saying and there will be an
eclipse for example
and they thought that there was a
connection between these sort of uh just
seemingly random terrestrial events it's
kind of like the analog of throwing a
die and seeing which way does it come up
and saying okay it's a six so that means
it's going to rain tomorrow
people didn't know whether that was the
way things worked or not and really
these three different cases of sort of
astronomical phenomena meteorological
phenomena and human phenomena like
winning and losing battles and so on it
the question of which of these was more
or less predictable and by what means
was really quite unknown in antiquity
and I suppose when it came to people
sort of being the astrologers they may
have done better at predicting the
outcome of battles than they did it
predicting the presence of eclipses
because the question of battles is sort
of some question of judgment about well
these guys have a stronger army or
whatever else or have better resolve or
whatever it is
um and that's something that a human
could know so the thing that kind of
launched sort of the the the science of
something like astronomy as opposed to
astrology was the realization that there
were regularities in the heavens and
that it was possible to kind of fit
those regularities to some kind of
cyclical phenomenon et cetera et cetera
et cetera and I think that the the
earliest kind of astronomy was really
this fitting of it's going to repeat
there's something periodic here we can
predict what the next element of the
period will be
well
then sort of in another Branch there was
kind of mathematics that came in through
Commerce and arithmetic and through land
surveying and geometry that was sort of
uh kind of became fairly clean and
abstract and and by the time of Euclid
first century BC I guess
um and uh the um
the question of second century BC uh of
that around that time the um
uh so it still was the case that
there was
only a very sort of empirical notion of
astronomy
by the time of people like Ptolemy
there were really geometrical things
that you could say about astronomy that
were essentially provable
from
uh euclid-style geometry like there can
only be at most I don't know what it is
five eclipses in a year just because if
you just look at where the Earth and Sun
are and it didn't really matter whether
the someone's going around the Earth or
the Earth was going around the Sun that
geometry was was really quite the same
same question at that time so that in
the in Ptolemy for example there's a lot
of kind of Euclid style theorem proving
associated with kind of where planets
and moons and things like this uh can be
but that
I would say that the um
the question of sort of what became a
real science
I think some was some things were known
about Optics and geometrical Optics
there's I think some lost work by Euclid
on that subject
and uh even people say that Euclid was
involved in the construction of the
ferros the Lighthouse at Pharos I think
um which was one of the Wonders of the
Ancient World
um that was a sort of geometrical Optics
story
but in any case the uh and
so there was a certain amount kind of
knowing about Optics and about these
things that were very geometrical
about mechanics
well not so much was known
in fact it took until the 1600s before
people really systematized talking about
mechanics and that was the work of
Galileo and then later Newton of being
able to have some definite thing to say
what became Newton's laws of motion and
so on to say things about what was true
about mechanics
now
that that was sort of rigid body
mechanics what happens to a projectile
that's sort of falling through through
gravity or something like that
around a little bit later but not too
much later uh came fluid mechanics and
things like Bernoulli's principle and uh
things about the compressibility or lack
thereof of fluids those kinds of things
but you know so the science of mechanics
was something that kind of came into
existence in the later part of the 1600s
and that really hadn't I think had
substantial precursors people hadn't
thought to kind of systematize these
things about Motion in that kind of way
they had observed the motion in the
heavens which is very regular but when
it came to motion terrestrial motion it
was all really kind of just well things
are kind of uh uh that there's there's
there isn't something systematic and
sort of scientific to say
so once these other kinds of things and
I think the real story of the
origination of Sciences is when does
there start to be something systematic
that people recognize to say about some
class of phenomena when can one take
that class of phenomena and essentially
make a a human understandable narrative
from those phenomena that really sort of
reduce all the details of those
phenomena to something where humans can
make some reasoning about those kinds of
things
so for example people had certainly
known certain facts about chemistry
since since Antiquity and people like
Agricola
in the Century A.D maybe uh maybe a
little later than that
um were kind of writing down things
about the preparation of metals from
oars things like this these kinds of
empirical facts about chemistry were
known
and it wasn't
there was then a long period of time
when kind of the the sort of the the the
big can we do this with chemistry
question was can you turn lead into gold
which was kind of the question of the
Alchemists
and that was a question that really in
some form or another pretty much
survived up until the 1800s and at that
time where people started having this
sort of systematic thinking about uh the
elements and atoms and different kinds
of atoms and periodic tables things like
this reactions being able to count the
number of atoms involved in reactions uh
by by using sort of numerical facts and
so on that was something that happened
really quite late
um and that became sort of scientific
chemistry became scientific when it was
I suppose one could say it was a
pre-science when it was really these
recipes for heated to this temperature
and throw this thing in and you'll
probably get this or that out of it but
there wasn't a theoretical layer to that
kind of science until the 1800s
now you know you could look at other
kinds of Sciences like biology for
example one could argue that there isn't
much of a theoretical layer even today
to biology you know we have two core
theories the theory of natural selection
and the fact of digital sort of the
digital nature of the genome and I
suppose we have sort of a pseudo-meta
theory that is things are all chemical
and there's lots of things that can be
said on the basis of what molecules are
present
but those are comparatively weak
compared to the theories of physics and
so on and in chemistry in in biology
there were certainly observations of
biological and medical phenomena going
certainly way back into Antiquity you
know another thing that sort of became
slowly systematic was uh this question
of just well there are all these
different Critters running around the
world all these different species uh can
one really identify can we really Define
what all these species are come and
classify them that was the the
contribution of Linnaeus for example was
this uh kind of thinking about the
hierarchy of species the the Filer and
taxa and and uh Genesis and all this
kind of thing that are the tree of life
that was a kind of a systematization
which led to a certain scienceization of
just oh well as there's pandas and
there's ant teachers and there's this
creature and there's that creature it
was a little bit of a systematization
and then with natural selection there's
a sort of well as a vague understanding
of how there might be this tree of life
although we still don't really know I
mean if you say prove to me
theoretically that the stegosaurus must
exist uh that's not something we're yet
able to do I have a suspicion that there
is actually more to be said about why
the stegosaurus has to exist than one
knows already uh just saying you know
one one is just looking at the
evolutionary the the fossil record and
just saying there must be between this
state of life and that state of Life
there must be a thing because evolution
is continuous that's as far as we pretty
much got there but to say what kind of
ornate forms might have Arisen or might
be able to arise that's something that
for which we need a different kind of
theory which I think to some extent we
have from studying ruriology and
studying the way that simple rules lead
to complicated Behavior we start to see
what kinds of elaborate Behavior are
possible from uh
from the kind of rules that can exist in
biology
but you know let's talk about other
kinds of science I mean geology for
example again uh these Sciences did not
arise until quite recently I mean people
had certainly noticed that this kind of
rock and that kind of rock but to make
something which is a more systematic
story of what's going on was a
phenomenon I think in geology again a
1600s type phenomenon I don't know the
history of that as well uh but um you
know then there are many other kinds of
things where is there a science is there
not a science psychology another example
you know by the late 1800s early 1900s
some ideas about psychophysics and sort
of being able to do the idea of doing
experiments on how people perceive
things or how people think about things
the idea of doing those experiments was
a slow idea to come in I mean people
were studying in the 1800s studying a
lot kind of the perception of color the
perception of sensations of toe own and
uh and hearing and that was something
again that psychophysics came in the
question of can we understand how
thoughts work and can we do that in a
systematic way well I think that's still
something we don't have a great theory
for I think we're beginning to see
actually from the successes of
artificial neural Nets we're beginning
to see some of the things which will be
potentially leading to more of a theory
of psychology or certain aspects of
psychology I mean the thing to
understand about scientific theories is
you have a general area like how people
think or uh sort of how different
species interact in ecology or something
like that
and the thing is you can have many
observations that are the things we we
traditionally observe but the question
is then there can be things about which
a theory can be made
and the question is do those things
intersect there could be a fantastic
theory about something we don't care
about there could be a theory that says
something like
oh I don't know some feature of economic
systems is this or that thing about the
sort of General aggregate probabilities
of flows of money in this way and that
way but you say well that's very nice
but actually nobody cares about that
that's a feature that in the current way
we think about economic systems is
something that nobody is paying
attention to and so this question of is
there an intersection between the things
about which there can be an abstract
Theory and the things that we care about
observing that's not obvious and that's
one of the things that sort of really is
the moment of scienceization and and
theoretical Theory formation is when
those two things intersect in some way
now you know we can ask about all sorts
of different areas I mean economics I
just brought up as a question you know
is there a science of Economics a
certain known phenomena there's certain
lack of kind of a core foundational set
of set of axioms I mean one might
imagine in that case that there's sort
of axioms about human behavior from
which you could build sort of the the
the consequences for economics from
those actions about human behavior but
that doesn't yet hasn't yet really been
terribly systematically done in fact I
don't know of examples I mean there are
there are questions in voting Theory and
things like this where you sort of have
an axiomatic belief about how human
behavior might work I mean in economics
there's sort of the notion of rational
agents and things like this uh in Game
Theory there's also some of these kinds
of Notions
um that are sort of axiomatic
assumptions about human behavior and
then there's a question of sort of can
you build the theoretical tower on top
of these and and typically I would say
that the my own view is that that hasn't
been outstandingly successful partly
because sometimes it will depend on the
things which are uh where you know you
make something axiomatic but humans tend
to be rather squiggly and not so black
and white in terms of what they do and
it may be that there's a case where it
doesn't really matter that the axons are
a little bit off by the time you built
the Tower up that that those kinds of
little imperfections and the axioms have
worked themselves out they've kind of
averaged themselves out and you have a
robust result or it could be that those
little imperfections in the axioms grow
to be more and more important and then
you can say essentially nothing
but you know it's interesting to see the
emergence of new Sciences I mean in in
uh in the time since for example
universities have been well structured
or structured and have departments and
things like that there are departments
that came into existence uh for example
molecular biology was one that famously
came into existence to a large extent
computer science was one that came into
existence uh maybe economics to some
extent as well uh the the many any field
like chemistry that predated the
formation of of sort of the modern
University will have been a pre-existing
kind of thing but the question is what
were the new ones that came into
existence another one that sort of came
into existence was Linguistics as
something other than a philology kind of
a study of the structure of language
this was kind of a a systematic science
like study of language as opposed to
philology which is more of a a kind of a
natural history of language and more of
a phenomenon analogy of language as
opposed to a theoretical approach to
language I'm not sure how successful the
theoretical approach to language that
initiated in the mid-1950s has been and
and once saw that in sort of the the
creation of lots of linguistics
Departments of for example American
universities that eventually ended up
getting closed now they're also sciences
that don't quite make it as sciences and
and again one sees things closing like
geography departments those were a thing
100 years ago and in the U.S and not so
in other countries they they haven't
mostly made it and that sort of ironic
given that sort of geographic
information systems and so on are now a
big thing and the whole notion of
geocomputation is now an important thing
and one can imagine much more of a
computational geography so to speak but
the actual sort of subject as it existed
didn't quite make it to the science
point
now I have to say uh that the general
sort of question of how do you make a
science what is a science this question
of taking phenomena in a particular area
and formalizing them and having sort of
theoretical things to say about them
there have been certain kinds of ways in
which to make theories I I've kind of
would say I've identified four of those
that exist over the course of of
historical time one is just
sort of the what are things made of type
of theory the the question of sort of if
you're doing biology oh you have this
type of cell and that type of cell for
example in biology what kinds of things
are present that's kind of the Antiquity
style of description of things then by
the 1600s we have kind of the
mathematical style of there's a formula
for that then the 1980s uh partly
through my own efforts kind of the
there's a program for that kind of
moment in the developments of of science
theories this idea that you can
formalize things as this kind of
computational layer where you're saying
the thing behaves according to something
which can be defined by rules that
correspond to a program that's kind of
that that uh that type of layer of
scienceization of things which is fairly
new this sort of the computational X
Trend that of making Sciences by using
computation as the formalization layer
rather than for example making Sciences
using mathematics as the formalization
layer or the sort of what exists as the
formalization layer now you know there's
a new game in town which is only a
couple years old which is this kind of
multi-computational approach uh which
maybe I shouldn't uh talk about too much
here but but this is this idea that has
arisen from our physics project in which
there isn't just sort of one thread of
time but there are many threads of time
and the Observer becomes an essential
part of the description of any system
necessary even just to knit together
sort of what is happening now what what
does it mean by now on these different
periods of time and we're starting to
see my own guesses that there are a
whole bunch of fields of science which
can be scienceized by using
multi-computation and the
multi-computational Paradigm I suspect
natural selection I suspect will go that
way I suspect a bunch of questions about
molecular biology and the foundations of
Life Sciences will be essentially in the
end where we formalize successfully in
multi-computational terms in a way that
has not been possible through any of the
previous paradigms for formalizing
things so that's kind of a new driver
for science formation I mean I should
say by the way that the sort of
computational X it's an interesting
question whether there are Sciences of
computational X Sciences where the X on
its own without the computational layer
doesn't really exist and certainly
something like Radiology the study of
what simple rules do almost by
definition is a is a only by computation
type of field but I think there'll be
there are probably and I'm probably just
failing to think of them plenty of other
examples of that phenomenon
so anyway a few thoughts about um about
sort of scientific disciplines in their
evolution I would say that the the the
formation of a science
seems to me to be more about
a class of phenomena where somebody
realized yes you can make a theory you
can make a science around these than it
is to do with the kind of budding off of
one scientific discipline from another
in fact there are you know when you do
see a budding off phenomenon it's it's
very messy usually because the new
science has new types of questions new
paradigm new methods and it really
doesn't fit it's really a discontinuity
I mean one could see that with computer
science versus mathematics you know it
could have been the case that computer
science kind of slowly butted off from
mathematics but really didn't because
the methodology is really quite
different it's not about proving
theorems and establishing sort of
aesthetic mathematical ideas it's about
writing programs for practical purposes
it's about studying uh computational
systems in the abstract those kinds of
things
so you know an interesting question is
whether
I mean in other kinds of Sciences have
Arisen and buttered off you know
Material Science for example Material
Science in a sense had a very long
history I mean it was a thing that one
could say was being done almost in
Antiquity but as a kind of identifiable
science
I would say that what happened is a
collection of phenomena kind of
coalesced into being things about which
science could be made and that turned
into Material Science probably in 1950s
and 1960s and so on and it wasn't a
thing that came out of chemistry really
didn't it a little bit came out of
Metallurgy but Metallurgy
um was something that was at some level
more of an engineering field than a
scientific field uh crystallography
was kind of a a slightly exotic
scientific field
um but those are those are some of the
origins of of Material Science and but
again I think the way that that science
arose was not by it's really being
studied in chemistry but then this
breaks off
now then there are some complicated
things that happen for example what
happened nanotechnology nanotechnology
1970s 1980s it sort of was a let's think
about making machines out of molecules
and so on it was really a
paradigmatically different approach from
something like chemistry which is we've
got a bunch of molecules bumping around
and how can we make reactions between
them and things like this a very
different kind of thing
um but then in the sort of dynamics of
the sociology of science the sort of the
thing that happened in the late 80s
early 90s was that there was sort of
capture of nanotechnology by chemistry
um and and really the smothering I would
say of nanotechnology at least for a
while by no no it really is chemistry
and and that happens when there is a
sort of a big institutional structure
around some field it's sort of close
enough that it can kind of capture some
other field
um and and thereby merge it or smother
it and I think that's um
that's sort of a phenomenon there I mean
I would say that in my own observation
of for example ruleology the science of
simple programs and what they do that's
a new name for it I mean in in the past
I've really it's been part of what I've
called A New Kind of Science and so on
although in general a new kind of
science is really about sort of the
computational Paradigm for science as
opposed to the mathematical one of the
past or the structural one of the more
distant past and so on but seeing kind
of how does ruleology fit in how does it
you know what is it is it a branch of
mathematics is it a branch of computer
science is it a uh uh you know what is
it well the answer is it's none of those
things and it's none of those things in
part because it's methods and the things
that it finds interesting are different
for many of those other fields it really
is a different a different clump of
stuff and I think that's been the case
with with most new Sciences is sort of a
different set of questions with a
different set of methods that that
discreetly come into existence rather
than being things that break off from
existing Fields you know I think Galileo
had a book called two new Sciences
um I felt very uh sort of Cut Rate when
uh in my book A New Kind of Science
because there's only one of it but
Galileo talked about two new signs that
I've now forgotten what those two new
Sciences were
um Galileo had been interested in
science and mechanics I'm not sure
whether that was one of those Sciences I
think maybe again but what he meant by
two new Sciences was a place where sort
of a new set of phenomena came under the
rubric of something that one could
discuss in a kind of systematic reasoned
way
let's see
uh
there's a question from Jamie
it's about Pleasant and past
do I think that Apple's new VR headset
will be much different than previous
releases of VR headsets what does what
the past releases of similar products
predict
virtual reality is one of these well
first let me say that the the Apple uh
Vision Pro headset
is an augmented reality device primarily
well sort of it's weird because it is
you can see through it but you can't see
through it with your own eyes it's kind
of a Darth Vader story I suppose it's
it's kind of a um uh you can
um
it has cameras and it is showing you on
on high resolution displays what those
cameras are seeing in the outside world
it is not the photons coming from the
outside world that you're seeing those
photons are going into cameras the
cameras are turning into Electronics the
electronics the electronic images is
being reformed for you and so that means
that for example when somebody's looking
at you from the outside it's a sort of a
weird thing because they are seeing a
simulated Avatar of you based on the
cameras inside that are looking at your
eyes and you know figuring out from from
infrared structured light on your on
your eyes where your eyes are looking
and so on and that's then being
synthesized by kind of a image synthesis
technology to what you actually are what
you appear like to other people from the
outside and I I noticed in Apple's demo
that um there sort of was a was a brief
section in imagining video conferencing
and imagining because you know if if you
are video conferencing with somebody and
somebody else is looking at you well
what they would see if they actually
were taking had a camera looking at you
is they would see this weird sort of
headset on you and if they see your eyes
they're only seeing the electronic
version of your eyes
but and they're not seeing the rest of
your face and so there's sort of an
effort to say can you deduce from the
local information with your eyes and
maybe some other cameras and sensors and
so on sensing kind of muscles in your
face can you deduce enough to be able to
recreate with machine learning what you
look like in in a way that's adequate
for video conferencing and it will be a
strange thing because one will really be
looking at avatars of people rather than
at the people themselves and maybe that
will progressively get better maybe it
will be horrifyingly uncanny I don't
really know until once tried it it's
hard to know but in any case so sort of
the Apple story recent Apple story is
really fairly different in a very rather
impressive piece of technology relative
to what has existed before I mean it's
really a pretty serious jump over all
the other sort of VR systems that have a
VR AR XR systems that have existed in
the past
but what's the history the history
I guess goes back
into the mid-1980s
uh the the real question for virtual
reality is what does it take to sort of
it's one thing to have a screen in front
of you where you're looking at the video
image or something of a thing
but it's another to have a head mounted
thing where as you turn your head you
get to see a different uh a different
image
just because you turned your head and
the virtual reality system knows from
accelerometers that you turned your head
and therefore it's showing you a
different piece of the visual scene
um the kind of idea of doing that seems
to have Arisen I think in the mid-1980s
um primarily and uh uh you know one of
the big issues there is okay you have to
have a fast enough computer that it can
repaint the scene as you turn your head
and as soon as there's a delay it's
horribly sickening to the user and I
must say I have always found VR devices
that have existed I haven't actually
tried one in probably a year or so
terrible
um but I've always found them that I get
terrible motion sickness when I'm using
them and I don't know whether that's
because my brain worked better or worse
than anybody else's but it is the case
that it really matters what the delay is
between when you turn your head and when
the visual scene changes just like you
know you're writing in a car and you
know you know when you've got motion
sickness and so on it's kind of like is
what you feel in your ears and then the
in the kind of sensing of of orientation
and acceleration you know ears is it
consistent with what your eyes are
seeing I noticed that Apple was claiming
a 12 millisecond delay time between
acceleration of your head and uh and
painting of of things on the on the
display and maybe that's short enough I
don't really know what all the other uh
delay times are to be um uh to be
adequate
now
you know okay so what was the history
well uh folks like Jaron Lanier were
very much into kind of this virtual
reality notion and uh there were all
kinds of other things because another
issue is when you've got this thing on
your head it's like how do you how do
you define what's going on and then you
have to start talking about gesture
recognition and being able to have
gloves and things that fit over your
fingers and and decide where they are
and so on and those were a little bit
conflated in those early years I would
say that the first time uh first time I
probably saw a VR system no the first
time I used a VR system was probably
1989 or so
and um that was had come out of some of
that work uh very much a a Silicon
Valley San Francisco kind of story at
the time
um some of it I think had come out of
NASA Ames Research lab in Mountain View
and um and so on I'm not completely sure
of that history but any case there were
an early company that really picked up
on this was Autodesk which was
um founded in I guess the mid-18 1980s
um uh by
uh this has an interesting founding
history and there's a there's a lovely
book by John Walker the founder of
Autodesk about um the history of
Autodesk
um that uh has a a very um I would say
uh uh a quite amusing take on uh kind of
the early history of a technology
company it's it's sort of notable that
they did a thing so different from what
I did in in the formation of my company
the the term Autodesk makes products
like AutoCAD and they brought in a
zillion other products now that do all
sorts of geometry mechanics card types
of things
um but uh originally they sort of had
five different products or something uh
that um they took to a computer show and
they just saw who cared about these
different products and the one people
ended up caring about a lot was this
computer design product that was a sort
of PC based computer design product
which had been the case that could be
ready to design products would like cost
100 000 dollars there's cost a few
hundred dollars
um and uh that was what really took off
um but the name of their company
Autodesk was kind of burnt in from the
thing that they thought will be the
winner which was some kind of sort of
pre-microsoft office kind of
productivity Suite kind of idea I
believe but any case Autodesk was a
company that really was the first one to
pick up on on virtual reality and say
this is going to be a thing that can
really be used what can it be used for
well architectural design which was what
Auto AutoCAD had then evolved to being
very much that was a core market for
them this idea of you can kind of go
into an architectural space and you can
kind of look around and see what's going
to be like a good idea in principle it
has in the past been pretty difficult to
make 3D geometry you know when you are
drawing architectural plans it's like
you've got the plan you've got the
elevation and then that's what you've
got and then the people who are
constructing the thing get to figure out
all the details of how to turn that into
reality now you know I know 24 years ago
when I was
uh getting house built it was a kind of
an interesting challenge to get can we
get some 3D geometry of some of this
stuff and that was kind of right at the
edge of where that was reasonably
possible to do but it was a lot of work
I think with modern machine learning
methods and kind of the whole llm story
image synthesis generative AI these
kinds of things it is in the process of
getting unbelievably much easier to
synthesize a a coherent 3D scene and
that will really change the story of how
easy it is to sort of go into a virtual
space in 3D and make virtual reality
make sense but when this was first
developing in the late 1980s none of
that was easy
so I think the first VR application I
tried was playing kind of Virtual Tennis
in VR now people then soon started
talking about uh
the other applications like molecules
for example being able to visualize your
molecules and in 3D things like this I I
would say that the uh look it's a
beating heart in 3D and you can move it
around I have to say that demo has I I
saw Apple showed that demo that demo has
existed since the very early days of VR
um
now you know I have to say by the I must
have been by 1991 or 1992 when I was
first thinking about these kind of
network models of space-time the thing
that I immediately thought about was as
I try and imagine this network that's
evolving and updating and I'm seeing
these places where it's you know glowing
you know Red Hots and and being updated
a lot in other places where it's where
it's not so to speak not really red hot
but just as a way of visualization
um the I kind of imagined it would be a
giant spider web and I'd be kind of
picking my way through the VR
microscopic universe and that was 1991
and we're still not there yet uh we
might now be just about to you know to
come to a little bit of closure on a
project to do something like that but we
are solidly you know 32 32 years later
um and uh it's not there yet but it's
interesting that it was already clear
what was conceivably possible back in
1991 it was a very clear kind of uh what
one can imagine doing you know you've
got this giant 3D Network and you're
pulling pieces of it like like spider
webs to kind of see what's behind it and
and things like this
but and then at that time there was a
brief piece of enthusiasm for 3D
displays on computers particularly using
lenticular technology but you would have
uh kind of um the uh
um uh kind of the these um sort of
cylindrical lenses built on to um there
was so gosh which one was it
ah
one of the Japanese
early computer companies
uh not Samsung not um Sony
uh boy one of the other ones
um had a a demo
um sort of lenticular lens lenticular
screen type thing which was a 3D screen
and
um I remember we had these in in like
1992 1993 at the company and uh we even
built some demos for it where you could
see these molecules sort of coming out
at you coming out of the screen at you
in 3D not not VR but but that was that
was sort of a 3D thing and it's worth
remembering that 3D movies have come and
gone many times
in sort of whether it was 3D movies
based on having um uh you know the early
thing was red and green uh you know
glasses where one eye had red filter
when I had a green filter then in more
recent times it's been uh polarizing
filters where you know vertical and
horizontal polarization for the
different eyes and those make different
images but 3D movies seem to have you
know come and gone multiple times and
haven't ever quite caught on I think it
doesn't help that when things when
you're looking through a polarizer
you're necessarily having only 50
percent of the light coming through and
uh so you have to have a brighter
projector I'm not sure people always do
have a brighter projector and so it just
looks dimmer and that's a bad deal and
so on
but in terms of VR the I mean the
technological thing that has happened is
is there a um is the field of view such
that you can are not just looking at
that display that's occupying the center
of your field of view but you're also
seeing to you know 140 I don't know how
many degrees out to the sides and being
able to sense things in your peripheral
vision your peripheral operational
peripheral vision is lower resolution
than our central vision but nevertheless
you can tell there's something there and
you can kind of tell the continuity of
objects from the periphery of your
vision to the center part of your vision
and that's a really noticeable thing
so I think for example uh this question
of can you do the Optics to really have
something where you have this sort of uh
broad peripheral vision that's been a
thing that for example Oculus was a was
a something of a breakthrough I think in
achieving that there's been well there's
been gosh such a long history in in um
in VR and there have been particular
Industries well Industries for example
military applications are pretty common
of uh uh of those kinds of things for
training and so on when it comes to
augmented reality again messy history I
mean the idea of a head-up display
heads-up display something very much you
know fighter pilots and so on you know
uh have had heads up displays
forever I mean I certainly back to the
1950s I think where you would have um
you know a a half silver mirror or some
such other thing and you're projecting
up
um onto that so that you can see it even
as you're looking through the windshield
so to speak I mean cars have lost decade
or more have more than that now 15 years
or so have been pretty routinely sort of
high-end cars pretty routinely have
heads up displays that's a kind of a low
resolution that's pretty standard
technology
then
there have been
gosh uh
there have been other attempts to do
this I mean another notable one was
Google Glass I mean there have been
companies like physics that have been
around forever and ever think
independently still
um building these kinds of things I
think primarily for military
applications
um the uh you know one of the questions
is how good is the resolution does the
thing actually work
and what are the use cases
and people well like 15 years ago were
talking about fragmented reality a
common use case is things like
construction
uh maintenance things like this where
you could say okay
uh the um
um you know construction workers might
get sort of the plans uh sort of
projected in virtual reality in
augmented reality so they know when
they're putting this piece of wood here
or something like this
um you know here's where it's supposed
to go because it's indicated in or
answered reality same kind of thing for
surgery of indicating sort of the
correspondence between some MRI image or
something and the actuality of what's
what what's there because the MRI image
can sort of see what is not not seen uh
you know in when you're just looking at
uh at the the the situation but um you
know I have to say I remember there was
one construction project actually it was
for a university construction project
where the people were proudly saying I
remember that we're going to use
augmented realities probably 15 years
ago now maybe maybe a decade ago they
were we're going to use augmented
reality to to do this construction with
all this elaborate concrete whatevers
and I'm like thinking to myself maybe
even probably said knowing me well that
means it'll be twice as expensive
um in other words it wasn't really a a
labor-saving thing at least at that time
um and uh
so you know there have been many cases
where the hardware hasn't quite worked
out the use cases aren't really clear
you know I just found
um something I wrote out in in 2012 I
think uh
about sort of potential use cases for
augmented reality that was at a time
when things like Google Glass were big
and I was like trying to think through
what would be potential applications and
I wrote These out I just tweeted that
out a couple of days ago and just for
fun because sort of AR is back again and
some of the applications that I have for
AR in that list are still very much uh
future you know forward-looking and some
of them are things where well okay we
already know how to do that by other
means like like we've got QR codes all
over the place so we've got um
uh we've got more accurate GPS and
things like this
so I think
um uh you know the real question is is
it really going to work
um
and what are the use cases I have to say
I probably shouldn't quote who said this
to me but I I will say a highly placed
person in the in the VR industry
um uh I was talking to what was it
probably is before the pandemic so about
three and a bit years ago and um we were
talking about uh kind of the new
initiatives for example from Facebook
and companies like that with their
acquisition of oculus and so on of you
know what do you what are people really
going to use this for
he said well the one thing it definitely
works for is if you're lying on your
back and you're watching television
that's a place where it works
and I did find it interesting that an
Apple's announcement this idea that this
thing is kind of it's really just a big
screen and yeah there are details about
you can have screens in different places
and so on but it's really a big screen
and I think that's probably a pretty
good application but to make that
application work you have to have very
high resolution you have to have rapid
response and you have to have a good way
of of kind of getting the input I mean a
another company that um visited oh gosh
four or five years ago now was magic
leap it was a company that had several
billion dollars of investment in kind of
the uh an augmented reality Hardware
device I have to say looking through
that device it's kind of the type of
thing where you have to actually visit
the company because nobody can show you
a web demo of augmented reality and have
it be useful but you know you put on the
device and it was it was very nice you
know bright display and could do all
kinds of things the problem was and the
secret of augmented reality for a long
time is it's all there very well and
good to say well I'm going to put on the
device the question is what's really
comes with that device is it a giant
helmet like a top hat basically full of
electronics or you know how does it
really work and and that has been a
challenge for these kinds of things and
I think Apple I don't think they said
what the weight of the thing is and that
clearly is a big issue I mean by the
time it's a a giant kind of um thing
that that's uh
um you know like a a heavy top hat or
something I don't believe I've ever worn
a top hat in my life now that I think
about it so I actually don't really know
what um
um
uh what they like to wear and certainly
with this concept of to pull it out of
your hat so to speak I mean I know in
the past people used to keep you know
papers and things in their hats and I
I'm I'm pretty sure that uh old Abraham
Lincoln when he was you know about to
sort of deliver a speech would take out
his hat and take take the papers out of
his hat maybe that's wrong but I think
that's right
um but anyway so I don't know what um uh
what it's really like to wear a top hat
I should it's one of those life
experiences I suppose one should have
but any case the um
it um uh the question is sort of what's
the what's the practicality of these
things you know for me I had thought
back in the early 1990s you know I sort
of was thinking well I'd like to get
more exercise I'd like to walk around
but I'd like to be able to keep working
while I'm doing that and I ended up I
thought gosh you know I should even if
I'm walking on a treadmill or something
I should be able to use Virtual Reality
to have my display and then I was
thinking of using a chord keyboard a
keyboard where your fingers are always
in a position but it's questioned which
which fingers you press together I
thought about using that as a way to
type things I had seen a chord keyboard
actually once visiting IBM research
that must have been oh gosh early 1980s
I saw that record keyboards never caught
on
so uh but any case the um I kind of
imagined that this was a thing I'd be
able to kind of walk around with I I
never found that to be practical and
then discovered that actually you could
just have a display and it turns out our
sort of motion compensation us as humans
is good enough that you can be just
walking on a treadmill or something and
looking at the display and you can keep
locked on the display and you don't
really have trouble sort of with not
being able to read things and then I
discovered that there was sort of a way
of putting up the ergonomics of a
keyboard so that you could kind of pivot
your hands in the right way and be able
to type up to about two and a half miles
an hour for me
um but any case the um
I think the you know in the theory of
it's really just a great big display
that happens to be fitted on your head
rather than being something you have to
carry I'm sort of looking forward to
being able to do my Pleasant walks
outside uh with uh with full
productivity with this thing on my head
so to speak but we'll see if that really
pans out but I do think this idea of a a
really very good display that is virtual
like this is is potentially very
powerful I mean there are plenty of
things where one can imagine well
whether it's video conferencing
applications whether it's annotate the
visual scene all these kinds of things I
think those are really unproven
um I think the idea that this kind of
well okay so there's a there's a
different branch gosh this is a messy
history there's a different branch which
is virtual worlds and I think that one
sees from my friend Philip rosedale's
Second Life which was kind of an early
multiplayer virtual world kind of thing
and then the question is to what how
important is it that you have kind of a
head mounted display and you have sort
of a realistic experience of the virtual
reality of those things how important is
that kind of metaversi idea and um
versus it's just on a display uh it's
always kind of the the the weird thing
is that you hear actual voices even
though what you see is kind of low
resolution and one of the things that's
very sort of notable about human
perception is often the sound matters
more than what you see you would imagine
that it's what you see that really
matters but what makes the animated
movie really come to life is often you
know the voice acting so to speak more
so than the details of how how good the
animation is and so on so you know the
audio channel does matter a lot and a
lot of these kind of virtual world games
you yes the the uh uh kind of the the
visuals are kind of clunky but the audio
is just straight audio
but I think you know what people found
in these virtual world games I mean
there are different kinds of things
there are there are games and I'm not a
a gamer so I'm not really well educated
on this but there are there are games
where there's really sort of stuff going
on produced by the AI of the game so to
speak and people are on quests and
things like that maybe working together
and there's a virtual world that's built
up around those then there are things
like second life where there's really
there's nothing going on except what's
created by the people in there now
things like Minecraft are sort of
intermediate because there's kind of
shared goals and so on but it's um uh
you know I think what's what's happened
is you know that one of the questions is
is the kind of non-ai
infused kind of um virtual world that's
just okay humans you're going to fill up
this virtual world as you filled up the
physical world I mean I think uh Philip
Rosedale is fond of pointing out that
there's sort of there's in a sense
there's infinite more space in the
virtual world than there is in the
physical world you can imagine sort of
building a whole well first sort of a
replication of I'm reminded of a company
I've been involved with called super
world which is a company that is sort of
selling virtual real estate in uh a
virtual copy of the physical world
that's yet another Twist on this whole
thing
so
it's uh uh you know what's going to
catch on in terms of whether one has
sort of a virtual world that is a
mapping from the physical world a purely
uh separate virtual world uh any of
those things relevant or is it just
augmented reality that's just you're
living in the world as the world is and
you're getting it annotated in various
ways or you're watching TV or or using
your computer display in that world I'm
not sure if I were to to guess right now
if the hardware is good
then I think what will what will pan out
is sort of just yet another display
device just as we had computers then we
had phones then we had iPads and we had
watches and so on this is another form
factor of display device and it may work
quite well and there may be use cases
like me doing my walks outside or even
something where you know I want to go
sort of super productivity and have 10
screens you know all arranged around me
you know sort of too much for just
looking around
um uh ordinarily
well let's see
um
memes is commenting VR stuff reminds one
of video game systems where the the
hardware might be fantastic but if the
content isn't there it's probably going
to fail I think that's why it's
important that the Apple device might
essentially just be a display in the air
because then all the content that exists
on display is just flat two-dimensional
displays it's all sort of fair game and
the fact that the thing happens to be
binocular and has 3D and so on well
that's relevant for sort of where you
place the the displays but it's not
deeply relevant in terms of sort of
visualization side of things I might say
that just to make a pitch for for our
world you know Apple has been developing
this AR kit that um allows you to do
sort of various kinds of augmented
reality and pseudo-virtual reality just
on a phone in the upcoming version of
Wilson language we have a AR publish
function where you can take sort of the
geometry of something that you've
created whether it's a you know
polyhedron or a 3D cellular automatic
and or some visualization of data or
whatever it is in 3D and you can just
say AR publish that and then you get a
QR code you point your phone at the QR
code and you get something that's sort
of a living
thing that is augmented reality on the
phone you can sort of place it in your
room or you can make it into the sort of
VR version and just sort of manipulate
it on your phone that's kind of a neat
thing
um chat comments these glasses and
headsets need to be comfy and
miniaturized to become suitable for
everyday use
yeah I don't know I mean you know many
people have imagined that you really
have to wait until it's the glasses form
factor and you know whereas the trend
for all of the stylish people has been
or many of the stylish people has been
don't wear glasses where contact lenses
don't have this uh this ugly thing in
front of your face
um for the last I don't know 20 years or
something maybe as AR comes to the
glasses form factor it'll be back to
wearing glasses again I mean this was
sort of a pitch but Google Glass was
that you know designer glasses and
you'll want to wear it type thing
um I don't know I think that that's uh
yeah that's a um uh that's certainly
something I I think um again to quote my
friend Philip Rosedale of Second Life
Fame you know he's pointed out that a
lot of people just don't want to put
something on their head where they can't
kind of see out where it's kind of a a
um or where when other people look at
them they see this weird thing on their
head
how that will play out in the Apple case
I I don't know
um
Lola is asking what cases are there in
education for these new headsets you
know one of the things that's just the
craziest thing about every new kind of
technology that comes out is people
always say and it'll be good for
Education people said that with movies
when they first came out a hundred and
something years ago people said that
with uh
with everything I mean people have said
that with uh
sort of
you know people said that with virtual
reality back in the day people said that
with uh these kind of virtual worlds
things it's always you know I you know
that this sort of uh you know tour tour
of the pyramids with an egyptologist in
a virtual world so to speak you know
they're always these educational
applications they often don't pan out
uh you know sort of the using computers
to magically transform education
is really something that has still not
yet panned out I mean computers are
useful for all kinds of purposes people
use computers as tools you know we've
built uh between Mathematica and more
malfur and modern language and so on uh
you know plenty of people using our
tools on computers for educational
purposes but the idea that the computer
sort of in and of itself is the magic
answer for Education didn't pan out yet
it may yet with llms we get to have sort
of a personalized tutoring bot that can
really personalize its responses and
really can learn the kind of the the
thought patterns of the user and
optimize the delivery of educational
content so you know maybe that will pan
out in that case but I think it's just
it's just such a a thing that you see
every time as people say it's going to
be used for education I will say another
thing about that when Mathematica first
came out 35 years ago in 1988 we're
about to have our 35th Anniversary later
this month uh when it first came out
you know it was widely used in
universities research Labs very quickly
and it started to be used in a few high
schools and I was like wow this is I
mean at the time it was usable on the on
the early Mac computers and things like
this as well as on higher end
workstations that were a bit too
expensive for the K-12 Market but it was
usable on Macs which were available in
the K-12 market and and used in that
market and uh I thought you know back in
1988 I thought oh my gosh I never
expected this this is really going to
take off at the high school level well
that was 35 years ago and I would say
that you know there had been many
successes along the way but it is
certainly not a a fully routine thing I
mean I suppose from alpha use is pretty
routine now at the high school level
sort of through the web but the idea of
of making use of these computational
tools it was very confusing because at
the very beginning some number of
innovative high schools jumped right on
and started using it and it's like oh
this is going to go great but then
there's a 30-year period it when it
really doesn't grow very much it's the
the sort of the high-end innovators have
have adopted it but there's a vast piece
of Machinery so to speak of other sort
of schools with other maybe budget
constraints but I think that's usually
that's not that's not the single
determiner of this but just sort of
mechanisms of how they work that just
didn't sort of uh didn't bring that in
for for years and years and years so
with these headsets there certainly will
be as there has been with previous
examples of virtual reality there will
be places where it can be used for
Education as I mentioned the military
have used VR extensively for education
and I believe they are also uh but for
sort of training for a long time and uh
that's and obviously when one comes to
flight simulators and things like this
for for you know airline pilots and so
on
um that's another place where things
like this have been used in these kind
of very high budget training
applications
that is a thing that is potentially very
usable in the case of sort of every
school kid it's just the the economics
are not there now maybe eventually the
economics will be there and it's an
interesting question if the economics
were there if it was um I mean Google
had this Google cardboard thing that was
some kind of uh faux VR type thing but
that's a that just that was kind of a
toy
um but you know when the economics are
really there to make VR something that
any school kid can readily have uh you
know what will that lead to I must say
maybe my imagination is insufficient but
I'm not thinking of sort of drama there
I mean I think it's it's another 3D
printing where people said though that's
going to be great for education and yes
what we saw again in that case was a
bunch of early adopters a bunch of kind
of specific innovators who really
brought that into education quickly and
then you know it's not the case that
that's a routine part of education and I
don't think it's compelling that it
could be I think it's something where
you know in manufacturing manufacturing
unique devices medical devices Precision
you know devices
et cetera et cetera et cetera 3D
printing is very much a thing
um but uh
you know I think again I I'm I'm maybe
my imagination is insufficient but I'm
not um uh uh I'm not kind of um uh
seeing it
uh for even even if the sort of price
point is is such that any kid can have
it
um I you know I think it's more likely
to be fun for gaming than it is to be uh
profoundly useful now you know having
said that uh our
former spin-off company touch press that
made uh iPad ebooks that uh and it's
kind of um was very much sort of uh faux
virtual reality with the first book was
a book about the elements that came out
at the same time the iPad came out that
involved these samples of chemical
elements that you could spin around I
shouldn't say this in the past tense
because you can still get that app
um the uh that you can sort of spin
around in real in on the iPad that was
kind of a sort of a pseudo virtual
reality and that was a very fine thing
in the end it was not commercially
viable
um arguably because every different you
know how many things can you spin around
and have fun spinning them around okay
there are samples of chemical elements
there are things like uh well we made
this deal to go into the field museum in
Chicago sort of after hours and
photograph their gem collection it's
another thing where you can kind of
uniquely sort of pick it up and spin it
around on the iPad and you can't do it
person because they won't let you in to
you know pick up the uh the super
valuable diamond or something like this
but the number of things for which sort
of spinning is interesting is is not
huge
um the uh you know that there are
different kinds of devices on them that
we had another one which I thought was a
nice app it was a kind of an x-ray based
app where you could spin things around
that were where you could change the
opacity and look at them with x-rays so
to speak and see what sort of inside
things that was kind of fun and then I
think
um the uh
uh in the department of of crazy
corporate stories and the spinning
around of things there was a uh kind of
the the uh I would say the the the thing
that perhaps broke the camel's back as
far as touch press as a company was
concerned perhaps was um uh there was a
big effort to get an iPad uh ebook app
um out in terms of how in time for
Halloween and there was this sort of
great idea of well there is a a
collector of skulls who has things that
you can put on a turntable and you know
take your your hundreds of pictures of
it and and make something which you can
spin around from it and they're about
the right size to put on the turntable
and so on let's make the book of skulls
so to speak
um and uh I was called skulls and it was
had a I think it had a physical book
that eventually got produced from it it
was kind of fun and had a nice nice text
um but any case the the book The Book of
skulls and spinning skull just missed
Halloween which was sort of a disaster
but in any case that was an example of
sort of faux virtual reality for
education
it's kind of interesting to look at
for a little while at least
spare parts comments some uh perhaps AI
can be used to translate existing
educational material into VR suitable
content I bet that's true I bet that a
lot of what is currently 2D imagery uh
just like movies are routinely using
ai-ish methods are routinely kind of
extruded into the third dimension I'm
sure that will be true with some
educational content I don't know how
compelling it will be I'm not sure that
it matters much I mean I think it's yeah
it's it's amusing to be able to see that
um uh you know that picture of a Dodo in
3D rather than just in 2D but I'm not
sure how profoundly compelling it will
be
all right I think we should probably um
uh
wrap up there let me just see if there
are any more questions related to this
particular topic
um
looks like there's some other good ones
for another time but I think it's time
to wrap up here for now and uh
thanks for um
asking oh boy a lot of interesting
questions here okay we're gonna have fun
next time well thanks for joining me
this time and uh bye for now